تمشي على ذات نهج موسكو وبكين.
والجميع يقول لامريكا سنفعل كل
المنطقة المزدحمة بالسكان.
مغامرة السائق منعت كارثة محتملة
شاووش اوغلو ان التطبيع مع تل
ابيب له تأثير ايجابي على حل
التركية اول دولة ذات غالبية
مسلمة باسرائيل واضاف ان التبادل
عدد من السيارات على خط سير
الشاحنة المشتعلة. وجهت السلطات
يا احفاد عثمان. فهل نسي الاتراك
قضية فلسطين? شاب ليبي يخاطر
اي شيء ضد الاعتداء الروسي.
روسيا تحظر دخول مائة واربعة
الصراع الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي. ما
كل هذا التملق لاعداء المسلمين
مواقع روسية. بوتين يوقع بتسهيل
منح الجنسية الروسية للاوكرانيين
الاعداء الى حفر نشطة اشعاعيا
حسب تعبيره. روسيا سداد ديونها
خمسون صاروخا نوويا جديدا في
ترسانة تستطيع تحويل كافة
البلدين الى الناتو. اوكرانيا
تطالب الدول الغربية تزويدها
الاحداث والتطورات. وفد سويدي
فنلندي في تركيا لمناقشة انضمام
انشطتها المشبوهة في مجال
الاسلحة النووية. نفط الامارات.
طريقها للوصول الى ميناء اوروبي.
ما الذي يريد ابناء زايد فعلا.
المنطقة الى الهلاك لان البلدين
ليس بينهما حدود وتفصل بينهما
العديد من الدول. بينما كشفت
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال
في خرسون وزبروتشا. كييف تندد
بالمرسوم الروسي وتعتبره اجراء
الامريكي وقوات الدفاع الذاتي
اليابانية عملية تحليق فوق بحري
العراق، لكن المخبر هو خائن في
الاصل والخيانة هي ما افسدت خطة
العسكري للهند لابعادها عن روسيا
بالاضافة الى ضم الهند الى اربع
عدة ابرزها ان الاخيرة تحصل على
معداتها العسكرية من روسيا ولكسر
والهادئ بدعم امريكي. بينما
تمتلك الهند رابع اقوى جيش في
تواجد الايرانيين هناك. كل ذلك
ينذر بحرب الطرفين قد تجر
العالم. فضلا عن امتلاك الهند
لقوة نووية تقارب مائة واربعين
يطلب اللجوء لاحقا. التحقيقات
الفيدرالي اوقع به بواسطة عميل
يستخدم سويتش بلين المسيرة
الامريكية لاول مرة لاستهداف
سيبدأان العمل على اتفاقية جديدة
بخصوص الطيران المدني. بينما قال
رأسا نووية. بايدن فشل في ضم
الهند كحليف لامريكا. العراقي لا
روسيا ولكنه لم ينجح حيث امتنع
رئيس وزرائها من التنديد
وخمسين نائبا بريطانيا الى
اراضيها. واكد الروس على ان
الشمالية ثلاث صواريخ باليستية
حسب ما اعلن الجيش الكوري
في المدينة وسط اشادات رسمية
وشعبية بشجاعة البطل. ومع احتراق
الخارجية بروبيل وزير الخارجية
الاوكراني. حلف الناتو لم يفعل
بعد ساعات من قمة كواد الرباعية
في طوكيو حيث اطلقت كوريا
الخارجية الامريكية برايس اجراء
الصين هذه المناورات مع روسيا في
بوليتكو الاخباري. بعد هذا
القرار الامريكي الذي جاء باملاء
واضافت ان شحنة تبلغ حوالي مليون
برميل من خام النفط الاماراتي في
الاقتصادي مع تركيا بلغ مستويات
غير مسبوقة متابعا البلدان
منسوب التوتر الامريكي الصيني
اجرت روسيا والصين دورية
وردا على التنسيق الامريكي
التايواني. وفي خطوة اخرى رفعت
اوروبا عن نفط روسيا فهل يقدر
الاماراتيون على اداء دور الروس
المصنفة امريكيا على انها
ارهابية وفقا لما نشره موقع
ينسى انتقامه. وصف بالعقل المدبر
لاغتيال جورج بوش الابن. الرئيس
الابقاء على الحرس الثوري
الايراني ضمن قائمة المنظمات
العمل على توسيع قائمة الحظر
الروسية سيستمر. الجيش الاوكراني
تعلن ابقاء الحرس الثوري
الايراني ضمن قائمة الارهاب.
لتنفيذ الهجوم وصل الى الولايات
المتحدة عام الفين وعشرين قبل ان
تصريح بايدن ان واشنطن سترد
عسكريا اذا هاجمت بكين تايوان
الثقافة الاوكرانية. قال وزير
الخارجية الاسرائيلية ارلبيدين
بحياته لينقذ الليبيين كما يفعل
الابطال في هوليوود دائما؟ قوة
الشمالية تتطاير قبالة سواحل
اليابان برسالة واضحة لامريكا
الوقت الذي تغزو فيه الاخيرة
اوكرانيا بانه دلالة على ان
اسرائيلي. اهي طهران وتل ابيب
على اعتاب تصعيد خطير وسط تقارير
في منطقة زابوروتشيا شرق
اوكرانيا بايدن بوتين يحاول طمس
اجباري للاوكرانيين وخرقا
لسيادتها. استهداف اليات روسية
لماذا تفعلون هذا ايها
العثمانيون? موسكو ستسدد ديونها
كوريا الشمالية يبعث رسائله
بصواريخ باليستية لتطال جولة
فرض الحظر على النفط الروسي.
قالت وكالة بلومبرج ان الامارات
الروسية الصينية قرابة ثلاث عشرة
ساعة في تحد صارخ لامريكا التي
كان مرتبطا بصدام حسين. حاول
تجنيد عراقيين اخرين واحضارهم
هل هم متأكدون من قدرتهم على
مواجهة مباشرة مع الدب الروسي?
بالروبل وتحظر اكثر من مئة
وخمسين نائبا بريطانيا وتقول
بدأت تصدير شحنات من النفط الى
اوروبا لاول مرة منذ عامين
ها نحن هنا في سماء تايوان وعلى
اجواء اليابان فاين انت يا بايدن
بعيدا عن محطة وقود. ليجنب
المدينة خطر امتداد النيران في
للمتضررين. الصين تتحدى امريكا
كما فعلت روسيا وكوريا الشمالية
بان الوضع في سوريا سينفجر
بينهما بسبب القلق الاسرائيلي من
تايوان? رسائل المجنون
الصاروخية. صواريخ كوريا
قال رئيس وكالة الفضاء الروسية
ان بلاده سيكون لديها عما قريب
براجمات الصواريخ المتعددة باسرع
وقت. في تهديد روسي جديد للغرب.
هذا التحالف العسكري. عرضت
واشنطن بيع المزيد من العتاد
الجنوبي ياتي ذلك بعد ساعات من
مغادرة الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
الامريكية ان طهران توصلت قبل
عقدين الى تقارير سرية للوكالة
الدولية للطاقة الذرية واستخدمتا
لصناعة السيناريوهات والتستر على
العلاقات الصينية الروسية لا
حدود لها. فهل تندلع حرب في
بحياته لانقاذ اهالي بنغازي بعد
قيادته شاحنة محروقات مشتعلة
استراتيجية جوية مشتركة شملت
اطلاق قاذفات صواريخ استراتيجية
المخبر انه يجب قتل بوش لانه
المسؤول عن قتل الكثيرين بعد غزو
بثمان طائرات مقاتلة للبلدين
حلقت معا فوق بحر اليابان فهل
الانتقام العراقي. الحرب تقترب.
قرر الولايات المتحدة جو بايدن
التنين الصيني. لثلاث عشرة ساعة
متواصلة حلقوا بطائراتهم واطلقوا
القذائف بشكل هستيري وبطريقة في
مناوراتهم لترد روسيا والصين على
ادعى انه عراقي لكنه كان مخبرا
ليحاول الشهاب مساعدته على
السن بالسن والبادئ اظلم.
وبخمسين صاروخا من الشيطان
الهجرة الى الولايات المتحدة
مقابل مبلغ ما لي. شهاب ابلغ
الامريكي الاسبق والعراقي ذو
الثاني والخمسين عاما شهاب احمد
وثلاثين دولة مشتركة لا تشمل
الصين في المحيطين الهندي
وكيف حدث ذلك? تركيا اول الدول
المطبعة مع الكيان الاسرائيلي.
الاسيوية فهل ترد امريكا على
ذلك؟ اما بايدن فيحاول استمالة
بالعمليات العسكرية الروسية في
اوكرانيا. واشنطن تغازل نيودلهي
الهند اليه بعيدا عن روسيا فهل
يفلح في كسر ذلك التحالف؟ واشنطن
حاول الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
انتزاع موقف رسمي من الهند ضد
بل هل تستطيع ابو ظبي تجاهل
تحذيرات موسكو شاب ليبي يخاطر
المنطقة بعد رحلة تعهد خلالها
بتعزيز الاجراءات لردع كوريا
الشمالية. ها هي كوريا الشمالية
تتحداك يا بايدن. فماذا انت
فاعل؟ وعقب اطلاق كوريا الشمالية
صواريخها الباليستية نفذ الجيش
ذلك اقصى ما يستطيع الامريكيون
فعله؟ الحليف الوفي. من طوكيو
هددت برد عسكري. فاين ردكم بعد
كل هذا ايها الامريكان؟ مجنون
؟ هكذا قالتها روسيا والصين حلقت
الطائرات وقاذفات الصواريخ
روسية من طراز تو ام اس ناينتي
فايف. ووصف المتحدث باسم
الاكبر ترعب روسيا الغرب فهل
يكفي ذلك? امارات تحاول تعويض
بوكالة الطاقة الذرية قبل عاما
من هو العقل المدبر لاغتيال بوش?
فكيف سيكون رد طهران يا ترى مع
اقتراب الحرب بين ايران
واسرائيل؟ ومعلومات استخباراتية
عن استيلاء ايران على وثائق سرية
ما يحلو لنا فماذا انتم فاعلون?